doesn't help that everyone I'm finding
has like different something happened
wait I just realize I'm probably gonna
be talking to strangers hi how are you
are you paying Master Mind okay I
actually don't know which one I'm
playing cuz it didn't work for me for a
very long time I don't know if it works
for way for you or not oh it has maybe
that's just what it was oh that's
interesting
okay this is actually my first time
playing so I'm probably gonna be really
bad I think I'm a survivor actually
thank you
exits open let's hurry
okay thanks for the heads up [ __ ] oh my
god
[ __ ]
[Applause]
I've been infected
cha-ching died
[Music]
Touche
ha
yeah no I definitely will it seems fun
do you prefer it to being a survivor
[Music]
yeah it seems like something completely
near as well so yeah I'm definitely
excited by that
ah
yeah
[Music]
that's a really good idea - yeah and
then also you lull them into a false
sense of security like oh this is gonna
be easy and then everything comes on
like oh crap
[Music]
yeah yeah I just see that in the
tutorial
nice CNI wildy thank you enjoy playing
bye
I'm sorry guys I don't play many like
online multiplayer games so as soon as I
remember that people couldn't be here
with me I freaked out I just freeze up
and I'm like oh crap I'm gonna be
talking to the real people they're gonna
be talking back to me to the whole game
it's just like trying nothing talk
oh it's erm he's like I'm sorry so you
come across as like super outgoing right
but I'm not as soon as the people as
soon as the people as soon as the press
and cadet she talk back to me I'm like
oh my god stop I can't oh it's so funny
this that was hilarious but it was so
cool but he was the mastermind as well
he's like telling us how he finds it
thank you for the ass Yaga muffin thank
you for $2 I appreciate that did you
enjoy my silent paper oh good thing is
though the Peters working we just have
to be a little bit patient you know just
a little bit patient so let's be a
mastermind this time oh crap wait
actually I wonder if there are any and
if I can go into the options and just
make it so that people can't hear me
that that would be nice
let's put voice chat off cuz I really am
just like yeah it's just I just I don't
want to talk to people please
cool you need a friend to play with you
I do
guys when this comes out would you want
to play with me we could do like a
little online games like I think this
was quite fun I mean I wouldn't pay 60
pounds for it but I pay 40 anyway I hope
yeah I hope you guys like that silent
silent all for maths survival play I
wasn't doing too bad it up until it died
shipping if I didn't think I was doing
that badly I thought I was doing alright
but you're talking to us I know is I'm
Alana Rick but you're not talking back
perfect
I don't know it's just like as soon as
it's like an actual physical person and
I'm a crud think it like then listening
to me right now I'm just like what do I
do
I don't know like yeah I just freak out
but yeah
so hopefully I think I don't know what I
did last time but I think I just left it
because I was looking for videos and
then it just worked right so I think if
we just be patient and just leave it
will actually get you out to play
hopefully
yes okay so this is literally we're just
we're just impatient beings although
there's no indication that it's
searching in these give us an indicator
game give us an indicator anyway
I'm Daniel when problems arise for
umbrella Daniel makes sure they go away
under the director direct orders of
Spencer assist Ferran is this Alex with
her research building facilities here
demonstrates Aurora whatever don't care
I'm Daniel was broadcast mode talked to
survivors directly and listen to their
conversations should we do that
I've tempest chat off though that seems
pretty cool I don't really understand
what it is is that what he was doing and
that's why he was talking to me I
remember I was like oh no someone's
gonna be here and then he was like hi
again I'm Daniel yang MINIX
there yo okay I don't think any of us I
don't think anyone can listen to anyone
that's good cuz that would be really
embarrassing
ah and so money I'm talking back all the
time can't you hear me ah talk about
louder so maybe I'll hear you then okay
wait
guys help me what do I do okay how do I
am where are my where are they
[ __ ] what am i doing what is my life
a machine gun
[Applause]
yeah boy what's the Berserker
oh [ __ ] what's this I'll [ __ ]
I've wasted something
[Applause]
I don't know what I'm doing anymore I'm
just doing everything brilliant [ __ ]
fantastic
here comes a dog me
you've gotta bite your kneecaps
Damus what do you think you're [ __ ]
doing in there I'm gonna getcha with my
Colin zombie
he's coming at ya
look he's there he's gonna get you get
your little little legs it's gonna get
your little legs when they saw me I
don't know what this is but I'll do it
am i doing now what does this do
I don't know a blinding flash of light
appears all right I'll leave them alone
I'm veena I'm being such a meanie nice
yes let me be you fools what happened
there well I guess he died [ __ ]
they blew out the camera no there's my
favorite camera oh yes
they're just staying there like I think
doing anything do they even understand
how to leave yeah [ __ ] yeah what is
happening why are they doing anything
what are these people does even know
that the game like I wasn't expert okay
it's fine
wait is this what the guy meant about
like taking my time not really putting
anything in the first place I think I
just used absolutely everything I will
be here I can't no no
good crappie I've got ya I got ya
yes dinky little human bean oh my god
where do they come from where did they
go where did you come from cotton-eye
Joe what who is she what is she I don't
know if she looks cool though I aspire
to be more like that lady
where are they what they do and what's
on the agenda
oh I can put mr. exile or but what are
these guys down put my strokes down here
there you go you're beautiful bastard oh
crap I didn't realize it took employment
straight away well I've just [ __ ] this
problem while you have a knife hello my
pretties
what were you what are you pointing at
don't fight each other boys and girls
wait is that player is a look like a
player this is Dom B where the [ __ ] are
they here I come
pulverise
I know wait wait you and me goodbye I'm
like look at me look at me
look at my beauty [ __ ]
[ __ ]
close this lovely outdoor
oh I'm not good at being this person is
good enough
yes that's right my party's you be
amazing
oh my god wait no screw this I got me
off died I'm gonna kill her
this bunny is fantastic he's the
fabulous zombie
No
damnit okay
yes Wow
I cannot see
can I use this one yes
Katzie too much is happening
Oh coals what'd she do she's onto this
leg like damn you don't leave me never
maybe
[Music]
damnit she's dead
I'll be meeting a yeo-hwa
I'm not happy about this wait that guy
is severely like it's not okay because I
don't know where they're going to go
either
where's the actual exit I know I want
some stuff around here
though here the minute we dress miss
traversing around the environment
I don't know what discount means what's
doing where's it going
don't you [ __ ] day man I know what
you're doing alright chuck them off the
side dummy I wanted to check them off
the side why are you listening to me
I killed my something all right
screw this he's coming in come on turn
around
oh these little nuisances look what they
did ohh hand oh we go up push there Oh
[ __ ] full sides
oh no nobody [ __ ] me this way clever
Oh Let Me In [ __ ] I'm a-comin
oh that's a [ __ ] zombie you little
idiot No
I did so badly wait did I win
Hey
I thought I'd see where he bought me
especially when I was mistake so I was
trying to be on my own freaking zombie
like wall I'm uh
Chinchin
yeah
much like she didn't even realize she
was I'm just used to coming to ask guys
can I say thank you thank you
Daniel smashed it uh uh I am a spin
control of Daniel actually saw me give
me the gratitude okay I'm gonna play it
one more maybe a couple more which one
should i paint which one shall pay again
I feel like I'm totally better at this
the mastermind but you are lit me to be
a mastermind or a survivor which one
would you like to see thank you yeah a
muffin for the two dollars and the epic
gave a moment to comment appreciate that
oh dear drink marrows not even know even
you overwhelm them but loving hug them
kisses hana did you know show some love
I just wanna show some love
sure I got candle burning and gets up
pretty much out which means I get to eat
it like pumpkin candle and it is so
freaking clay because it smell good I
love spices okay yeah so what what game
are we playing are we playing a survivor
or are we playing Massa mind which one
German play again
Mack which we do i won I don't know
I hope she reads the rest of my stupid
comments anytime which ones some Elana
beak
you clearly the mastermind at mastermind
which I guess at least I do like one of
each again so do you yeah I'll be a
survivor I'm a survivor I'm gonna make
it will actually survive time hopefully
not we shall see
so epic man can't handle so Eddie I'm
gonna switch out my candle oh I'll take
January sorry I know you wanted me to
Pete I rumba I'm being January yeah it's
like such a quick turnaround of like
what you have - so what does she do
uses EMP to impair or cameras are so I
can do that to the cameras it's January
structuring greatly increases mess when
scale cast oh oh that's good that's good
it's for a long weird day oka don't
touch me
disables cameras yeah I know just
basically what you told me
can you touch arounds cool
connect the armory to new please stock
it's pretty cool oh okay
than y'all
he is being manipulated by Francis Drake
hmm hmm hey potato farmer yeah I haven't
seen you around here in a long time oh
[ __ ]
sorry give me things I want things I
want the stuff two guys and 39
do I have an arm
[ __ ] it I'll do as she knows
give me another green hair a my left
give me a blue one them Cheers
okay yes guys are still here I know
you
oh wait whoa whoa
teleport and I'm crazy teleporting lady
so were they it teleporting doors should
have really got like a male a wife but
not something as well
I've got me a lot of green herbs this
good thing okay there's dog in that blue
out to do these pile is I'm the worst
team a I'm just here for myself
oh cool okay yeah sure you you think we
can get out can we
okay cool no we can lies slander Oh
shizer shizer shizer this is cheating I
don't think this is very bad Becky oh my
god
stupid ass dog whoa how do I keep
freaking teleporting is it just her that
does this I'm very confused oh my god
this game is crazy guys this is what you
get when you play very every agent oh
[Music]
right
turn around quickly little
huh check ready to go
sorry for getting so aggressive guys
I don't mean a just a naturally scary
person what can I say all right my
friends need help
what's up with you why you smart you
coughing up now you need to kill things
Jesus Christ what is wrong with you
woman why do I have to aim why can't I
just why can't I just freakin shoot
without aiming because he's going too
fast you to aim and for this server like
and like I'm telling you to shoot and
you shoot a second after and this is not
OK and I'm don't enjoy this and this is
non enjoyable and you keep coughing how
am I supposed to help you when you
[ __ ] cough all the time we stupid
sorry I'm actually getting very annoyed
why is this [ __ ] zombie oh my god now
I need to be loud
Wow well we were the worst team in the
history of team that ever were the
team's this is so bad
[Music]
how the [ __ ] hahaha I need to buy all of
the things please
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh boy I can't see I
can't see I'm the floor
Oh No hey buddy hey pal
I'm up hey it's a human centipede hey
buddy oh yeah we're not gonna win this
one this mastermind knows what they are
doing a vacant piece but the overtime
stuff as well because it just does not
seem to really make a difference yeah
you get overtime for like three seconds
you get up off the floor and then you
die it's like what why what is that
useful how am I supposed to buy in that
overtime am I supposed to survive at my
overtime that's given to me but to me it
makes no sense no sense
oh hey Kaylee I don't think you can be
stealthy in this game perfectly balanced
logical game yes young a muffin
Tyron didn't carry the team no and
freaking carry bad team we were all
we're all bad all of us come on
alright let's try and be a mastermind
again and while I wait for this to load
I'm gonna off enough candles I never hit
my knees hands ring and life is gonna be
amazing
that's nothing
I took too much a tyrant AB yes I did
take all the hurt tonight I just you
know just like migraines what can I say
nice this room is gonna smell so good
hey chick so late night
I don't know what's going on this game
neither do I put a partner like that
that was the worst experience I've had
so far what with them uh just rubber
banding and just everything teleporting
everywhere that was really difficult to
keep up with and there was delay on the
gunshots as well which is very annoying
but you know if this is beta bound to
happen well we shall see we shall see
yeah yeah Gwen better not knock that
candle over and quit we're ages I can't
was like and then you guys are slowly
watched my room just like go in flames
and I will literally be that mean just
they're still playing like everything is
fine I am fine oh my god did you choose
my presets I didn't do this last time
tonight
I don't know don't really care
I guess that one
vampire I can smell it already smells
great
yeah a limited server capacity no I
definitely I mean this is probably why
one of the main reasons why they're
doing the pee test right is there are
many fun adventures the server can
handle destruction disease all the fun
things that the modern world will offer
us destruction on dizzy sorry
good friends for you this one I call the
drip stir because bits are dripping off
there yeah you you're great
be so kind as to wait for their present
that will go
we that could be Aki
if that was something you needed do you
think it would thank you we that could
be Aki
ineffective in the long run still alive
mostly yes each other out
Fatah's more cards to turn for you yet
wanna me this is a zombie a dangerous
one
it's a dog no no come up yes yes
I call this one the poison in nature
poisoning natives yeah I could so this
is Daniel didn't know he was the funny
funny guy funny guy yeah he's gonna get
sense of humor and all that sometimes
it's easiest just to do things yourself
he understands me
this is indicating sometimes it's
easiest just to do things yourself yeah
it's him to power him have fun with him
eita no don't I eat you know we set this
up to tease you do you not we never
really expected you to get it
a fittingly brutal weapon for a brutal
game
where are the other
where are they what is that noise
sorry yeah goodbye
where are the bloody hell are they um
hello
I spawned just for you and did not even
hear how rude
haircut what fascinating it's not it's
not all bad mother all the way there
they do ban all the way over here
pansies
sometimes it's easiest just to do things
yourself you understand me oh come on
oh come on I'm always just a little bit
too far away
not this time mister not this time you
are mine you're mine for the hugging
damn it
a single bullet like this will rarely
kill you unless you're already weak do
you feel strong today
I call this one the poison inator poison
inator this is the deadening Dan no fun
and cool friends for you
sometimes okay gonna be the cool girl
zombie TV cam and going to command them
and then again
wait Jesus Christ is so much like
where's the people and where do people
at where do people I'm doing a good job
I do feel like so being the mastermind
you are pretty oh what's the word like
you have a much higher chance of winning
as the masterminds I don't feel like
it's balanced enough towards the
survivors
maybe that's just because we need to
learn the maps fast and like we're still
getting to know everything I'm obviously
as I page when I paid this from
survivors last there were some serious
server issues going on but you know I am
more so enjoying being the mastermind
I won I'm okay are these skull points
like amounting to anything can I keep
them
you're really good at being evil Thank
You semolo there's no better pick it is
my true calling in life
especially the evil French accent well I
just copy what I was hearing so you know
kind of kind of easy
I think anyone gets Deloitte so how's
your first impression of this perfectly
excusive well-balanced game I think I
like it's told you now I am actually
enjoying it I think you know what though
I really do miss the game at the games I
I do miss the days of split-screen
gaming and I think games like this are
just made for that like couch co-op you
know sit there with your friends have a
few friends over have a few snacks have
a few drinks and just play and yeah I
just have fun together
I totally understand but nowadays it's
like much easier and it's more
accessible to just do it online but I
miss just having actual people around my
house and playing video games with them
instead of just being online so yeah I
think that's one thing that I do miss
just because it does remind me a little
bit of left for dead obviously and that
was a game that I would always play on
sleepovers and stuff like that
try saying my name with your evil French
accent I can't stop laughing imagining
it oh jeez I don't like at what I do
anymore like oh let me get back into it
like I can't like oh I don't want it I
don't offend any what I want is stop
worrying yes okay um
Zombieland of each Domino no big no I
can't even that's so embarrassing
like shut up yes okay catch go up yeah I
miss cover to cover up what game was
that the camera recently though that was
couch come up these gears get five wears
couch co-op which is cool to see a new
game kind of bring that back why don't
you stream this on Twitch
to be think more people can find me on
youtube and I'm not using you J use
what's the chords oh crap was it cause I
found I but I use I use restrain us
alone
so stream on both but I'm doing this in
my PlayStation so I had to choose just
one anyway let's try survivor one more
time and see how it goes
Oh oops
I pressed master man go away no let's
tries to buy go on one more time let me
see what happens
now tell the moustache while saying it I
don't wait what are you trying to say I
don't have a moustache when you say it I
shaved it this morning
I really hope they do make another
Resident Evil survival game though
reminiscent of Resident Evil 7 I I know
they're gonna be making more remakes
which I do pretty enjoy the roommates as
well so I will play this obviously you
guys know but yeah I do hope that they
make another one maybe he doesn't have
to be standalone but I just like the
whole first-person survival horror
aspects and Resident Evil 7 was just so
good there's just so many elements
elements to it and so many different
gameplay parts like when you found the
videotapes I knew that she just had to
hide
when you went into the brothers play
thing he'd like had that whole kind of
like I wanna play a game saw ask
environment few for you to do puzzles
and things at that end that was so fun
that was so different to the rest of the
game and it also just took aside I won't
be Valerie what you thought you knew
about video games so that was pretty
cool so say everything you thought you
knew conflict on his head with him just
not dying and stuff Jack right and then
but then people treated that to the
remake because you think headshots
they're great no oh really gonna come
back up anyway see him in the leg and
then they'll have a broken leg and even
if they get back up and just like well
is easy wait back up then we'll be able
to get back up so right what can Valerie
do let me situation for us a it's great
oh yeah okay that's cool
make neighbor items and threats making
them easier to Omar from the yeah
okay so I thought these are things that
like I could choose but I guess it's
just stuff that just comes innately with
being had
I have seen revolution slaughter poverty
and riches I want this oh she's so cute
it's like me every day when I go okay
I'm not afraid
dunks this
green hair traps traps this traps I told
you that you didn't listen to me those
traps
oh Jesus Christ
Oh [ __ ] chazer how do I do that again
there's a lot I love good she's shot it
go on then you open the door what did I
just do
I just went into a different room go I'm
not a team player at all um I am such a
little
cool we're here already nice
what do I need to repair here for
there you go on the team player you will
come on tyq okay by the way there's a
trap that I don't don't fall for it but
there is something on here so I will go
but [ __ ] sake what did I just say haha
got spray I just healed you and you
didn't even say thank you you even look
at me to say thank you you like I think
that's quite personally so I'm just
gonna get all the hurts myself
can't see I think I have another gun
here somewhere
I don't know why this thing where am I
[ __ ] going
[ __ ]
there we go
oh great we probably won't eat it no
don't lock yourself in that one go
outside and Rikki Jesus Christ and Oh
oh yeah there's no point trying to kill
mr. X what am i doing I'm a freaking
idiot
I think I died I think I liked being her
best buy oh my dad I'm not dad but I
can't see what's behind my
that's the main thing
okay whatever we're not having the ammo
for this guy
how am I going to cut and you can go and
see what I have prepared for you next
they really want to get in that dog Wow
I'm just gonna walk past bye guys see ya
what Cassie
why am I going I'm trying to get
somewhere
[Music]
that was my teammate
so getting confused our first random
[ __ ]
I just can't tell
ah what are you doing stop closing the
freaking door you idiot
okay
oh boy I feel
okay we seriously just like figure out
what the [ __ ] Madhu
do we do it
did we do it
don't [ __ ] with me did we do it I think
we have one more though
right okay okay one more guys
healing spray ready when we need it
group up for healing help that's better
there you go you guys are welcome
okay so thank you through those steel
doors is a safe room that it's a name
[Applause]
[ __ ] sakes Fosters
yeah yeah I agree with this guy this
guy's like mr. right now yes I say men
you should probably golf
he's doing no damage thank you that was
all on me I'm gonna take about all of
the credit wait ah guys down wait come
here oh shut up stop nagging me Megan
I was gonna go help my friends oh I'll
go try and help them how oh it's alright
you can help
[Music]
now come on we're doing so good we can't
do we can't fail now
wait here I know hey I was trying to
heal him okay where is the other one
[ __ ] I didn't press that button so who
did oh it's a gang
well I don't know why I'm going ah
I don't know when the other one is I
don't know who at the other one end
[Applause]
you're so close
we're so close
oh but actually annoying we were so
close
hey Kelly I do played fi daylight
i streamed it once I think oh that's so
annoying
we were so close to winning ha mana
saman so annoying
haha okay anyway that is the end of the
beta for this is way too glitch I know
mm Eric but yet so this was the beta for
project resistance how did you find it
let me know I know there were some
issues especially the seconds
playthrough of the survivors but that
last one was actually pretty good there
was no real issues that I could notice
but then it didn't see me yeah yeah I
don't know maybe it was just with that
one character but yeah we'll see anyway
so that was fun and I enjoyed being the
mastermind it it's nice to flip flip the
narrative you know and be one of the
ebrill monsters for once we serve always
funny way from any game okay that's what
was so cool about left dead when you
play online you can play as like a
boomerang I mean everyone wants to be a
tank but it was just so cool because
you've been playing left 4 dead for a
while anyway offline and then all like
couch co-op and then you go online and
you're like I get to be these zombies
that I'm scared of when playing the
single-player version of the game it's
just super empowering it's really cool
um but yeah that's right Luke as I said
a Wimpy girl what this game isn't really
scary so hmm evil French evil girl plays
but then everyone will expect me to be
French like a guy can't keep up that
accent it's not even good for nighttime
yeah I'm glad you enjoyed it for it
anyway I'm gonna start saying advice
this is as I can see in the chat now so
thank you everyone for joining me and
don't worry I will be back soon this
week has been very very hectic in work
I haven't been getting home until very
late most nights so well not very late
but like late enough for me to just want
to make dinner and crash so yeah but
whenever I find the time to stream after
work I will and if not we have the
weekends so it's all good but actually
at the moment I am working towards
making fingers crossed making a horror
video for you guys I've got a horror
story that I've written and I'm trying
to make an in-game cinematics so just a
little bit um you know what's the word
huh
what's the word I'm trying to think of a
little bit ambitious that is the word I
was looking for just the tired ambitious
but we'll see we'll see what